qué tan fundados son los temores
alemanes de que Rusia pueda cortar de
repente el flujo de gas es decir no hay
contratos vinculantes de por medio
qué tal Valentina Muy buenas tardes
buenas noches a todo tu auditorio y en
efecto si hay una serie de contratos que
se tiene que cumplir en este caso el
operador de de gasoducto está
Estableciendo Que bueno hay una un una
operación de mantenimiento ya programado
que es este durante estos periodos del
11 al 21 me aparece son 10 días en los
cuales es un mantenimiento general sin
embargo las zonas subsiste o subyace por
virtud de unos problemas operativos que
tiene el operador de de este de este
gasoducto respecto de unas turbinas de
compresión de gas que esto es lo que le
da presión al al producto para llegar
hasta Alemania desde Rusia hasta
Alemania entonces estas turbinas están
en el continente americano están en
Canadá y bueno Rusia y el operador están
alegando que hay también alguna este
dinación de la entrega de estas turbinas
imputable también por este tipo de
cuestiones geopolíticas de ese conflicto
ruso ucraniano bueno Qué opciones le
quedan a Alemania para encontrar otras
fuentes energéticas porque ya han
considerado importar gas natural licuado
pero el país ni siquiera tiene la
infraestructura para recibirlo
si ese es un gran problema que bueno
desgraciadamente el gobierno alemán se
ha procurado a sí mismo dado que ellos
hicieron un apagón nuclear
recientemente este apagón nuclear a
diferencia por ejemplo de Francia que
ellos pues recientemente están haciendo
llevando a cabo estas políticas para
reactivación nuclear es lo que les está
dando el respaldo Y de alguna manera
seguridad energética que eso es lo más
lo más importante aquí desgraciadamente
Francia Alemania por estas relaciones
que tiene ya de muchos años de décadas
atrás con Rusia y este acercamiento
digamos que en algún momento los países
de la Unión Europea le habían comentado
a la anterior Premier alemana que era
una situación bastante riesgosa sobre
todo por la política expansionista que
estaba llevando a cabo Rusia sobre
Europa del este bueno iba a cobrar
factura desgraciadamente el apagón
nuclear está ahorita a Rusia a Merced de
perdón a Alemania Merced de Rusia y
bueno esta situación pues puede puede
desencadenar de desencadenar una serie
de problemas tanto económicos como
energéticos para este gigante económico
europeo que o soluciones tienen al
alcance de sus manos Bueno pues regresar
obviamente al carbón que es una de las
bases que Ellos tenían anteriormente
Pero esto contra gran día también a la
política de descarbonización que tiene
Alemania comprometida con el resto de la
comunidad Europea y la comunidad
internacional bueno el 45% del gas que
importa a la Unión Europea proviene de
Rusia Qué tan grave Sería para el bloque
este corte súbito Cuáles serían los
países más afectados
bueno de entrada el más afectado sería
Alemania ya ya sabemos que Polonia
ahorita pues este está haciendo un
cambio
derivado también de estos Cortes y
fueron en Francia es el segundo afectado
Pero ellos ya están llevando a cabo un
regreso a las energías nucleares